I think we're now ready to start talking
about some general trends in the
periodic table and the first one that
normally comes up in a lot of first-year
chemistry classes and it even shows up
on some chemistry standardized tests is
the notion of ionization energy
ionization energy and what this is is
essentially the energy required to
remove an electron from the state the
the neutral version of that atom so
let's say it's the energy energy to
remove an electron and just in case you
haven't been exposed to the idea of what
an ion is I guess this is a good time to
explain it and then this will make sense
so an ion is essentially any atom or
molecule and we'll talk about molecules
molecules are just combinations or
groups of atoms that are all bonded
together in some way and we'll talk
about bonding in in a few videos from
now but it's an atom or a molecule in
which the protons the protons don't
equal the electrons and if the protons
don't equal the electrons then you have
some charge if you have more protons and
electrons you have a positive charge
right so let's say if you have hydrogen
let's say you have hydrogen normally
it's neutral right it has no charge but
let's say you were to remove an electron
from it so now you have hydrogen plus an
electron hydrogen only has one electron
outside so now it just has a proton on
the inside no electrons the outside so
now it has a plus one charge right we
could write a minus one there and now
what we have done in this I guess we
could say this procedure or this
reaction is we've removed we wrote them
we we've ionized hydrogen we've removed
an electron and in this case this type
of ion that hydrogen is where your
protons are greater than your electrons
and is just a nice word to know this is
called a cation a cation is an ion with
a positive charge now you just as easily
could have a situation where you have a
let's say
I don't let me take a an element let's
say we start with chlorine CL right in a
stable form it has seven valence
electrons and wait let's why don't we
add an electron to it and now it'll be
CL and now this will have this actually
be pretty stable have eight elect a
valence electrons but it'll have a
negative charge so this right here this
is a negative ion and that's known as an
anion anion the way I remember it is I
don't know a lot of words
eh-eh means the opposite or negation
right the a prefix so a anion means a
negative ion that's and then obviously
cation is the other but ionization
energy it really should maybe be called
ket ionization energy because it's the
energy required to remove an electron
not remove or add an electron so it's
really the energy required to turn
something into a cation into a cation so
we've already discussed the periodic
table and we'll get to this chart in a
second but just based on what we already
know which elements will it be harder to
remove an electron from and which ones
will be easier we already talked about
let's start with Group one just because
it is Group 1 group ones right here and
we'll start especially with the alkali
metals we can put hydrogen inside for
now but all of these guys we've talked
about a lot in order for them to get to
the magic number eight in their
outermost shell the easiest way for them
to do it is just to get rid of that one
valence electron they have in their
outermost shell so this you know let's
say let's say potassium right there
potassium has one valence electron in
its fourth shell if it just got rid of
it then it has eight in its third shell
then it looks a lot like argon from an
electron configuration point of view
which would be nice so these guys really
want to give away electrons so it
requires very little energy to to ionize
them to or to cat ionize them to take
away their electrons so this is low
ionization energy low and I think you
you see where this is going
what about these guys well what about
what about
Gyan how hard is it for to remove an
electron from neon well neon is
completely satisfied it doesn't want to
even deal with any of this reaction
business and bonding business it's like
you know what I've achieved happiness in
life don't mess with my electron so it
really doesn't want to give away its
electrons neon or Krypton or argon or
any of these noble gases so to remove an
electron from one of these guys requires
a lot of energy so this is a high
ionization energy so in general as you
go from left to right across the
periodic table it goes from low to high
and some people they memorize this but
you really don't have to memorize it you
just say look these guys have one extra
electron that they're always trying to
get rid of these guys has two so it
requires into you know ideally they'd
want to get rid of maybe both of their
electrons but in the first electron
doesn't want to jump off as much as the
first electron here because the first
electron here you get rid of it
you immediately get to the super stable
state and that trend just becomes more
and more true this guy definitely no
under no circumstances wants to give
away electron this guy so close to being
like neon that he definitely doesn't
want to go step backwards and look more
like oxygen so he doesn't want to get
rid of an electron so the trend is
pretty clear anytime you're confused
about the trends just look at the
extreme cases this guy wants to give
away electrons this one guy wants to get
electrons so if you say what's the
energy required to take it away electron
well this guy is almost going to give it
to you while this guy is going to be
very hard especially neon to take away
an electron now what happens is you go
down as you go down in this direction
let's say you go along a group right we
already established that these alkali
metals they'd like to give away
electrons but as you go down the the the
electron cloud gets bigger and bigger
and you could say this 55th electron
there's 55th protons there's also in a
neutral cesium atom there's also 55
electrons that 55th electron is a lot
further away from the nucleus of this
atom than this then the third electron
is in in the case of lithium so this
this the 55th electron not only does it
want to be given away but it's a lot it
has even a weaker attraction to the
nucleus and the third electron does have
in lithium so at because you're getting
larger and larger as you go down a group
and your the electrons are getting
further and further away from the
nucleus this guy wants to give away his
electrons even more than lithium does
right so ionization energy decreases as
you go down even though even though
xenon really wants to keep his electrons
he's a little bit more willing to give
them away
the neon is right so in general this is
activate the the ionization energy or
the energy required to ionize an atom it
will increase as you go up right and if
you ever forget it don't memorize these
things because that might be useful for
just one test but then later on life
when you're 42 and someone asks you hey
what's what has a higher ionization
energy cesium or fluorine if you you
might have forgotten it but then if you
look at a periodic table you'd say oh
you know cesium it has this one electron
that is just dying to give away it's
super far away from the from the nucleus
that that that 55th electron just really
wants to leave while fluorine its elect
that ninth electron is you know it just
needs one more electron to become oh say
neon neon is super happy they're really
all the electrons are in the stable
configuration they're close to the
nucleus there's a lot of Attraction with
the protons in the nucleus they
definitely don't want to give away their
electrons so if you talk about the
energy required to remove them very low
energy it's cesium very high energy add
helium so that's the trend and this is
just you know this trend we'll see you
often this is how willing are you
willing to this is your willingness to
give electrons and this is how much you
want to hog electrons or keep them to
yourself and this right here this is
actually that got this off of Wikipedia
this is actually the actual measured
ionization energies and people looked at
patterns like this I'm not sure if they
actually looked at the ionization energy
but they looked at patterns like this
and this is actually where they came up
with a periodic table because they said
look you know as we add as we increment
up the number of protons that we have in
an
and likewise the number of electrons we
see these these repeated patterns or
these periods in in the elements so this
is hydrogen so hydrogen ionization
energy is around 13 and 1/2 electron
volts right which is a unit of energy it
can be converted into joules if you like
but then all of a sudden helium is a lot
more stable it takes almost almost
double the energy to remove that last
that that second electron from helium
because it's so stable but as soon as
you do that as soon as you go from
helium this point right here that point
right here is lithium right lithium is
atomic number of 3 let me put that in
the this is lithium all of a sudden to
remove an electron from lithium it only
requires 5 electron volts so less than
half of what it required for hydrogen
and then as you go then as you go to the
right of the periodic table the
ionization energy keeps increasing I
mean these these little divots are
interesting we could talk about that
maybe in a future video but then the
ionization energy all increases all the
way to neon and then you get to neon and
you add one more see neon is noble gas
it's completely happy then you add one
more electron you get to sodium and you
say oh and now sodium it's really easy
to take away that electron and the
ionization energy drops and not only did
it drop but here it drops slightly below
lithium so you see this general trend so
these are the noble gases right here let
me make sure you can see them all in the
video screen helium very hard to remove
that 8th electron neon it's very hard
but a little easier than helium and
that's because neon is a little bit
bigger the electrons are a little bit
further away from the nucleus argon same
pattern but it's actually interesting
argon is actually not that different
than then hydrogen on a Krypton same
thing it's hard to remove that electron
but it's actually no harder to remove
the electron on Krypton then on hydrogen
then xenon and you go all the way out to
all the way out to radon as you can see
you know Y is the distance between these
increasing well if you remember the
periodic table xenon and right you know
all of a sudden when you get to when you
go after argon then you have all of the
d-block elements that go in so after you
get to argon
to notice this is where you only had SNP
block elements SNP block elements and
all of a sudden the D block elements
show up so you have more a L'Amour set
you have more sub shells to fill up more
sub shells to fill up and now all of a
sudden you're starting before you get to
radon you're starting to fill out the F
block too and that's why that distance
is increasing because you have to also
fill out the F elements but there's the
general trends that we just discussed
they apply here that as you go to the
right along a periodic table it becomes
harder and harder and move an electron
because everyone wants to get to the
magic number eight and it's very hard to
remove them from a noble gas but then as
you go one more above that this guy
would love to give away his electron and
get back to and get back to a
configuration like neon and then the
other trend is as you go down a group as
you go down a group in this case this is
the these are the the noble gases the
ionization energy decreases and that's
because just the overall radius of the
new Covey
increases so that that kind of that the
valence electrons and radon are a little
bit less strongly attracted than the
valence electrons in helium anyway I
think that's it for ionization energy
I'll continue this in another video
we'll talk about metallic character and
electronegativity